I was very weirded out by the Aesthetics
of the
um Vision Pro headset by Apple and not
so much because I don't like the
technology I'm very curious about what
it's going to be like and have don't
have an opinion yet but uh the
Aesthetics of the presentation and so on
were so uncanny valley-esque to me the
characters uh being extremely plastic
living in some hypothetical
um
myth Century Furniture Museum yeah
this is uh the proliferation of
marketing teams yes but it was a CGI
generated wealth and was a CGA generated
well that doesn't exist and when I
complained about this uh some friends
came back to me but these are startup
Founders this is uh what they are what
they live like in Silicon Valley and I
try to tell them no and know lots of
people in Silicon Valley this is not
what people I like there's still people
they're still human beings
so the the
grounding in physical reality somehow is
important too
um in culture and so basically what's
absent in this thing is culture there is
a simulation of culture an attempt to
replace Culture by catalog by some kind
of
um aesthetic optimization that is not
the result of having a sustainable life
a sustainable human relationships with
houses that work for you and
um a mode of living that works for you
in which this product
um these glasses fit in naturally and I
I guess that's also why so many people
are weirded out about the product
because they don't know how is this
actually going to fit into my life into
my human relationships because the way
in which it was presented in these
videos didn't seem to be credible